hello YouTube just lovers in reference
this is guns in here
and welcome to my 13 chest strap now
when you play E for that is one opening
which you will likely to meet at all
level of Chasse
that is the opening called sniper now
sniper can be characterized by these
three moves by the black so black can
start with the move g6 followed by the
move Bishop to g7 and then quickly go
for the move c5 and no matter how white
responds these three moves are pretty
much on the card and the problem from
the white perspective is if you don't
have any system against the sniper then
you come into a serious pressure early
in the opening so that's why it's very
essential for you to have some kind of
system against the sniper now what
happen in this video is I am going to
show you a particularly nice chest strap
which many sniper people are not aware
of it and the good thing is even though
if your opponent doesn't fall for it you
get a nice easy to play position as a
white so let's see this strap right
we'll start with the movie four and
black responded with the move g6 and
here I propose you go for the main line
which start with the move b4 and when
the black responded with Bishop to g7
you play Knight to c3 here obvious
response will be the C file by the black
which has a mate of attacking that ball
and here white will capture the ball so
as per the main theory of the sniper
black will always place this Queen to a5
move now Queen to e5 move is a
dual-purpose move so not only it's tried
to regaining the pawn but you can also
see it's specializing this Knight
so white response is pretty much forced
so white has to play Bishop to d2
when black recaptured that phone here
comes the stunning reply which is Knight
to d5 now Knight to d5 has one drawback
which this b2 point is right now hanging
and if black vicious black can capture
this pawn but again you will see that is
one of the side line trap which I was
going to show you in this video the good
perspective from the white side is black
has only few accurate moves left which I
have highlighted by the arrows over here
which are light to e6 and b6 but how
many of you opponent knows this I bet
not many because most logical moves
looks like e6000 and erful chess travel
so let's see this in one of my game
my opponent responded with move e six
which has a merit of attacking my knight
but now comes the very forcing sequence
which is Bishop to b4 please note Queen
has to watch out the c7 square otherwise
Knight will go to the c7 and it will
folk the King and rope so the only
logical reply left for the black is
Queen goes to the c6 but I wonder if you
can spot the next amazing move by white
please pause the video and find out
winning move by the white and that move
is Bishop to b5 BAM
so forget about the rock now black queen
is strapped so you can see this queen
doesn't have any place to hide and if
queen capture this bishop now comes the
complete family folk which is Knight to
c7 and black queen is a goner so that is
one of the main trap exist in the sniper
and up till now I have many victims when
you play Knight to d5 there is a another
trap which black can fall into and if
your opponent is greedy then he will
likely to capture this pawn with the
bishop so Bishop cross b2 which has a
mallet of attacking the rook and white
response is pretty much force so white
has to play a rook to b1 and if the
bishop drop backs any other squares then
black will fall into our main trap so
the only logical reply left from the
black is Bishop to d4 which has a merit
of attacking the f2 but here white has
again the pretty good trap which start
with the move Bishop to b4 so it has a
merit of attacking the black Queen and
after Bishop cross f2 white can
cold-bloodedly play King to e2 now
please note Queen has only square left
which is d4 it doesn't have any access
to either III or the b6 so black has to
play Queen to d4 but afterwards White
has a stunning reply which is Bishop to
c3 so you can see there are some nasty
is looming first of all this Bishop is
skewering this Queen and the rook and
not only that White is also threatening
Knight to c7
here there are two reply for the black
in one of my game my opponent plays
queen cross e for and I simply snap up
the bishop and still my threats remain
the same so in this game my oven and
doesn't last for long in another game
my opponent plays Queen to C file which
looks somewhat sounder because it's okay
that black rook is hanging right now but
so as why it's night and that means
black will continue with his attack so
here white can simply reply with Knight
to f3 and in the game my upon responded
with Knight to f6 because now that rook
was hanging but I simply now place
Bishop to b4 attacking the Queen and now
Queen cannot defend that bishop so in
the game my opponent plays Queen to c6
afterwards I simply snap up that bishop
and this is one of the fastest game I
won in the sniper in the game my
opponent goes for this track so Knight
cross e for afterwards I path marking on
g1 and then he responded with Knight to
c6 which has a merit of attacking this
bishop and also protecting the c7 that
means the Queen is become free but here
white has a very strong reply which is
Queen to d4 so it is attacking the two
piece so black response is pretty much
forced so black has to play Knight to f6
afterwards white will play Bishop cross
a2 so now again two pieces are attacking
the knight so that means black has a
force reply which is Queen captures d5
but afterwards I play Queen cross f6
attacking the rook and after very nature
looking
to g8y it has a mate in six after this
move which is look to even now in the
game my opponent plays d6 and I want you
to pause at this time and find out the
mating sequence
okay it's run like this so I first of
all play Bishop to d8 giving a
Discoverer Jack to the black king if the
King goes to the f8 then that leads to
the mate in two so in the game my
opponent responded with King to d7
afterwards very simple will be rook
check and please note black King cannot
capture the bishop if black king
captured the bishop then the very simple
will be route cross b7 with a discovered
check and after King to e8 we have a
lovely checkmate King cross d8 it's
impossible so in the game my opponent
goes to the c6 but afterwards White has
a very simple check which in screen to
c3 now here black has a to reply if my
opponent played night 2 C Phi then the
very simple will be rook check and after
King to b6 we have Queen to b4 checkmate
so that is again fast checkmate in the
game my opponent played this cunning mu
which is Queen to c5 which has a merit
of checking my King as well and somehow
my opponent feel that he can do a queen
trade but I refuse everything with this
wonderful move which is night to d4
check and now my opponent King has to go
to the only square which is Queen to
defy afterwards I give him this check
which is Queen to f3
please note black has the only reply
laughs which is king cross d4 afterwards
Queen to d3 as a checkmate
so I hope you enjoy and learn this
wonderful trap and the sniper
please try in your own game and make
your opponent to think about his opening
thank you for watching my video and
please feel free to comment it bye